new york 2015 einer der größten
wissenschaftsverlage der welt wurde
beklaut und verlangt 15 millionen dollar
schadensersatz von zwei haben einer
riesigen schatten bibliothek für
wissenschaftliche paper doch von der
verantwortlichen fehlt jede spur
entweder ist sie so etwas wie der robin
hood der wissenschaft oder sie arbeitet
für den russischen geheimdienst je
nachdem wen man gerade fragt aber wer
steckt eigentlich hinter sap und wie hat
diese eine frau ist geschafft millionen
von wissenschaftlichen artikeln von fast
400 universitäten zu klauen
lasst mich nur soviel sagen legal ist es
nicht und dennoch ist sie für viele
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
eine hält russland 2009
alexandra elbert jahren aus kasachstan
ist eine junge forschung studentin an
der russischen akademie der
wissenschaften in moskau
hier lernt sie eines der größten
hindernisse für angehende
wissenschaftler und studierende kennen
haywards dazu müsst ihr wissen
wissenschaftliche artikel egal ob
öffentlich oder privat finanziert gibt
es fast nur in sogenannten science
journals und wenn man ergebnisse sehen
will dann muss man diese journals dafür
bezahlen
ein artikel kostet in der regel um die
30 euro oft aber auch deutlich mehr und
ein jahres abonnement zu einem solcher
journals kann bis zu 5000 euro kosten
und ich meine es gibt für jede
wissenschaftliche fachrichtung hunderte
dieser journalist kann das schon
ziemlich teuer wir haben 2010 geht elmos
für mehrere forschungsstipendien erst
nach deutschland und später in die usa
sie forscht einem gehirn computer
interfaces über die wir auch schon ein
video gemacht haben
aber der frust über die barrieren in der
wissenschaft wächst vor allem
nachwuchsforscherinnen und forscher
werden meistens sehr schlecht bezahlt
für veröffentlichungen in journals gibt
es keinen cent aber sehr häufig kostet
es sogar geld paper einreichen zu dürfen
gleichzeitig sind drei viertel aller
wissenschaftlichen texte im internet
hinter einer paywall die girls verdient
also sehr gutes geld mit der forschung
anderer menschen aber im umkehrschluss
wird es super teuer an wissen
anzukommen was wenn man sich so ein
journal nicht leisten kann
wie auch schon viele studierende vor und
nach ihr wendet sich direkt an die
forscher über bestimmte hashtags auf
twitter hofft sie dass wissenschaftler
ihre arbeiten privat weitergeben das
klappt oft genug das machen wir auch
häufiger aber eben nicht immer also
stellt sich die frage was wenn es ein
system gäbe paper die man unter der hand
bekommt einfach weiter zu geben
kasachstan 2011 elf jahren hat die
nötigen computer skills und kontakte in
die online paris szene um ihre idee
umzusetzen und so wurde es sei hart
geboren hier ist wissenschaft für jeden
verfügbar
kostenlos aber illegal sie selbst
beschreibt es als verwirklichung ihres
traums menschen zu helfen gute ideen zu
teilen ohne barrieren aber ihr handeln
bleibt nicht ohne konsequenzen nicht nur
offline muss elfer kann ab jetzt oft
ihren standort wechseln
auch im internet ist 2 hab auf der
flucht so ist die seite über mehrere url
erreichbar wird eine seite durch die
behörden gesperrt dann wird einfach die
nächste genutzt aber egal welche domain
sei hat ist kostenlos und bleibt es auch
weil es sich rein über spenden
finanziert auf der website kann ich
einfach die idee also sowas wie die
wissenschaftliche isbn oder den link zu
einer studie eingeben und voila
ich habe zugang entweder war das
gewünschte paper schon vorhanden und es
wird sogar live für mich besorgt wie
funktioniert das
mittlerweile befindet sich ja quasi
alles online und natürlich ist alles was
online ist nicht 100 prozentig sicher
universitäten bieten für studierende und
wissenschaftler online zugänge zu
journal sun mit den richtigen daten kann
sich seither automatisch bei einer von
hunderten universitäten einloggen und
beschafft sich das paper innerhalb von
sekunden
sowas kann natürlich nicht legal sein ob
die wissenschaftler und studierende ihre
login daten freiwillig weitergeben oder
ob sei habe anders daran kommt das
möchte elba kian nicht sagen
von kritikern wird ja auf jeden fall
vorgeworfen phishing passwort cracking
und sogar noch aggressivere hecking
methoden einzusetzen
einer ihrer lautesten kritiker ist
andrew pitt er behauptet eine so große
und kontroverse organisation wie sei
habe erzeugt viel medienrummel und
rechtliche probleme damit so etwas in
russland stattfinden können muss der
russische staat mit an bord sein
ob das stimmt oder nicht können wir
nicht wissen an dieser stelle ist auch
wichtig zu erwähnen dass pitts
anscheinend selber interesse daran hat
dass paper weiterhin geld
kosten oder wie es ein arbeitgeber nennt
für die richtigen nutzer zugänglich sind
wer auch immer die richtigen nutzer sind
wahrscheinlich sind dass nutzer die geld
ausgeben können usa drei jahre später
amerikanische behörden nahmen
ermittlungen gegen zwei hab auf
angeblich arbeitet elf jahren mit dem
wir zusammen den russischen
geheimdienste der auch für die geliebten
e mails von hillary clinton
verantwortlich sein soll
große enthüllungen hat es allerdings
bisher nicht gegeben sebastian selber
streitet alles ab
nach eigenen angaben arbeitet sie
alleine um zu verhindern dass spione in
ihr netzwerk kommen
woher ihre spenden hingegen kommen
können sie nicht wissen moskau 2015
nachdem die ersten kritischen stimmen
gegen zwei hat laut werden reicht der
niederländische wissenschaftsverlag lc4
klage gegen alexandra l baki an ein und
verlangt 15 millionen dollar die spur
führt nach russland denn dort stehen die
server von 2 habt doch der
aufenthaltsort von elf jahren bleibt
unbekannt
anstatt das hype nicht gemacht wird
sorgt der gerichtsprozess führt genau
das gegenteil sei hart wird größer denn
je die anfragen auf google und auch die
freigeschalteten paper auf sub schnellen
in den folgenden jahren in die höhe der
streisand effekt lc4 übt währenddessen
europaweit druck auf internet provider
aus sei halb zu blockieren
offiziell weiß man in deutschland von
nicht aber zum beispiel bei mir zu hause
komme ich ohne ein bpm da nicht aufs ei
hab mein anbieter nennen wir dann
einfach mal telekom spricht auf
nachfrage von einer technischen störung
mal ganz ehrlich wenn das so eine lange
technische störung ist dann spricht das
nicht wirklich für den service oder für
die glaubwürdigkeit dieses anbieters in
verschiedenen ländern haben provider dem
druck von lc wir bereits nachgegeben und
2 habt blockiert unter anderem in
österreich übrigens wenn ihr trotz ihres
internetanbieters zugang zu sap haben
wollt dann bleibt bis zum ende des
videos dran denn da haben wir für euch
noch ein besonderes angebot von unserem
sponsor 2021 standort unbekannt nach
eigenen angaben schreibt elbert jahren
gerade ihre doktorarbeit an einer nicht
bekannten privaten universität das thema
wissenschaftskommunikation und teilhabe
ist da so etwas wie der praktische teil
ihrer arbeit
inzwischen wurden über eine milliarde
artikel auf sell herunter geladen und
fast 90 prozent aller wissenschaftlichen
literatur ist aufs abzufinden
währenddessen sind behörden und anwälte
weiter fleißig damit beschäftigt sei
habt dicht zu machen
bisher allerdings ohne erfolg elmar
klein selber möchte die bibliothek
weiter ausbauen und bald sogar eine
suchmaschine anbieten
es ist ganz schön schwierig sich eine
objektive meinung übers abzubilden
auf der einen seite ist es eine super
interessante plattform mit einem
revolutionären open source ansatz und
auf der anderen seite gibt es wüste
anschuldigungen ist zwar habe jetzt als
etwas gutes oder etwas schlechtes
alexandra elbert jahren macht das was
journals eigentlich tun sollten
wissenschaft zugänglich machen denn
wissenschaft muss open source sein
allein schon weil ein großer teil von
studien öffentlich finanziert ist
sollten natürlich auch die ergebnisse
öffentlich verfügbar sein
und selbst wenn sie das nicht wehren
wissen sollte allen gehören wissenschaft
muss nicht profitabel sein
wissenschaft muss mehr wissen schaffen
um die welt besser zu verstehen
egal ob sich das vermarkten lässt oder
nicht trotzdem gilt natürlich sollte sie
methoden wie phishing oder patchwork
tracking benutzen ist das meiner meinung
nach mega verwerflich ob der zweck die
mittel heiligt das muss natürlich jeder
für sich selbst entscheiden es gilt auch
benutzung auf eigene gefahr
eventuell nicht auch mal aus versehen
auf sei - hauptpunkt se gewesen aber
natürlich nur aus versehen und natürlich
nimmt sich das nicht schon seit jahren
ohne probleme weil das wäre ja verboten
und fun fact für informationen in diesem
video hier führt auch kein weg an großen
verlagen vorbei
zum beispiel diese artikel hierüber sei
habe oder dieser hier alleine diese
beiden artikel kosten zusammen 80 euro
während sie sich für ein open access
prinzip aussprechen bisschen ironisch
oder und damit kommen wir zum sponsor
des heutigen videos nord wie pm
viele von euch können wahrscheinlich
nicht einfach so auf zwei halb oder auch
auf andere webseiten zugreifen aber mit
nord pm ist das kein problem
jpn einzurichten ist kinderleicht und
erlaubt euch das internet so anzusteuern
als würde dir in 60 ländern überall auf
der welt sein so kann ich zum beispiel
auch dass netflix angebot aus anderen
ländern schauen
dexter oder twin peaks gibt es zum
beispiel nur in den usa
mit norton sind aber diese serien nur
einen click entfernt
und bei der geschwindigkeit muss man
auch keine abstriche machen es gibt
unbegrenzt bandbreite und zumindest bei
mir zu hause habe ich keinen unterschied
mit oder ohne nord vpn festgestellt
manchmal sperren internetanbieter seiten
aber nicht einfach so wie bei sub
sondern sie priorisieren andere
verbindungen deswegen kann es vorkommen
dass zum beispiel game downloads abends
mal etwas langsamer sind und auch so
etwas kannst du mit einem vpn einfach
umgehen und das beste ist mit dem kot
doktor watson bekommt ihr sogar einen
monat gratis wenn ihr euch ein zwei
jahres paket holt und keine sorgen ort
wie entspannt keine nutzerdaten und wenn
ihr nicht überzeugt seid dann habt ihr
30 tage zeit was euch anders zu
überlegen und euer geld zurückzubekommen
wenn euch das jetzt interessiert dann
geht auf nord pr.com / doktor watson und
auch der erste link unten in der video
beschreibung oder benutzt beim checkout
den code doktor watson um euch einen
monat gratis zu sichern
wie immer vielen dank fürs zuschauen
bleibt neugierig bleibt gesund
patrick